[موسيقى]
كيف تاره فوق خشبه المسرح ويطل تاره عبر
شاشه تلفزيونيه وتنقل بين ادوار مختلفه
فقد يكون جاسوسا او محاربا فذن وربما يكون
بطلا خارقا بثوب صحفي ليصبح اسم توم هاردي
اللامعا في سماء هوليود لكن ليس قبل ان
يترك ماضيا مليئا بسلوكيات الانحرافيه
وتجارب ياساء فما قصه
ولد ادوار توماس هاردي عام
1977 في لندن لعائله مبدعين فوالدته رسامه
ووالده كاتب ومع ذلك اعان خلال طفولته من
مشكلات كثيره فقد كان يشعر بالخجل من
مظهره وشخصيته الحساسه كما كانت علاقته
مضطربه مع والده بسبب سلوكياته غير
المتزنه فطالم وقع في مشكلات في مدرسته
اما اثناء المراهقه فقد بدا رحله صعبه مع
ادمان الكحول ولاحقته تهم تهريب المخدرات
وفي واحده من التجارب السلبيه قبض عليه
بتهمه حيازه السلاح شكل ميل توم للتمثيل
احدى اهم نقاط المضيئه في حياته فذهب يبحث
عن الفرص للوصول الى الشهره فطرق ذهب عروض
الازياء من خلال مسابقه متخصصه قادته
لتوقيع عقد رسميا في عام 1980
كما سجل لدراسه الدراما في احد المعاهد
المتخصصه بلندن لكنهما لبس ان طرد بسبب
غيابه وعاداته في طعاطي المخدرات ومع ذلك
قدم له الفن فرصه للخروج من ذلك العالم
المحبط فحصل على دور ثانوي في المسلسل
التلفزيوني باند اوف برذر لعام 2001 كما
حصل على دور داعما في فيلم الحرب بلاك هوك
داون شكل الادمان والسلوك الانحرافي لتوم
عثاره امام انطلاقته الحقيقيه كما كان
سببا لفشله في زواجه وهو ماذا فعله اخيرا
لي الانخراط في برنامج اعاده تاهيل وهو ما
سمح له بالبدء من جديد اثناء فتره التعافي
قدمتهم عروضا مسرحيات ناجحه كما ظهر في
عدد من العروض قبل ان يتجه لتاسيس شركه
للانتاج الفني في عام 2009 تم اختيارها
هاردي لبطوله فيلم ذا تي التابعي لسلسله
مارفل سينماتيك يونفرس عندما حصل على دور
الرئيسي لادي بروج وهو الفيلم الذي حقق
عرضه اكثر من 850 مليون دولار وهو ما اهله
للحصول على شخصيه فينوم في فيلم ليديربي
كورنيج التابعي للسلسله نفسها في عام 2021
وفي مكانتهم شابا منحرفا اصبح منتجا فنيا
واصبح مقبولا لاداء العديد من الادوار
البطوليه في افلام ناجحه مثل
رورو
فنان وغيرها
فحصل على عدد من الجوائز ابرزها جائزه سي
من الخطوات الناجحه فانتجت العديد من
البرامج التلفزيونيه مثل تبوك
مع شركه ام بي سي يو العالميه والشهيره في
الانتاج في عام 2014
قدم هاردي نحو 50 عملا فنيا خلال مسيرته
حتى اليوم وجمع ثروه تقدر بنحو 55 مليون
دولار ليصبح احد اهم نجوم هوليود ومن
اكثرهم اجرا لكن النجاح الحقيقي كان تحوله
من مدمن مطرب الى نجم وشخص ناجح يشار اليه
بالبنان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]